foreign
[Music]
it's going to go into your Center
I don't want to go around yourself
do you see that
I go I go aim yourself
but it's easy because you're and that's
why it's a drill is your Center is
stabilized it's always going to be there
it's going to be there okay but now when
we do this technique
your Center is not there
I had to get your Center where I can do
the cookie dosa
[Music]
so I don't want to go around your Center
you see that
I don't want to go over your Center
the hand goes
right into your
Center
onions
mom says not here it's not a sumia touch
it goes right
into there
[Music]
feel that okay
okay
so I'll do uh some references that that
elbow right there
That Elbow here okay because this this
this is where uh his his Center is in
this locked Nest he's not locked okay
this is gonna undo the slapping in his
body he's
so it's here and I keep that
just as a reference point okay you're
not going to be able to especially the
person that's coming forward and you're
you're not going to be able to
externally do it it's not like the
elbows pushing him
and you get it you can't externally do
it do that okay but his body is locked
not where your projection is
the elbow
now I know you see my hands traveling
through space like here's my hand you
see that and uh as you see me enter you
see it
go off and you see a coating here
but it's not that I'm here and I try to
do that
so I'm here I'm locked she's locked and
I move
and do not open there you see that
and pop
you got it okay so why does my hand open
it's just keeping that I.T adhesion
keeping I'm staying with him it's not
throwing him you get I'm staying with
him so I think when you guys go his hand
open and you're going like that
[Music]
Network
what channel version is doing if you see
more of his energy
there's more of that
[Music]
you just have to resist it I would still
like to see you enter
I still interested
but eyes
prefer that you do this connection
if you want to take your arm out
but what you cannot do
is take his elbow
give it back the slack okay so this
movement you'll kind of think of you're
going to do
uh
the body's tight
you're not going like this
you get it you're not making big circles
before screw his body as you Corkscrew
yours
[Music]
so he's his as I tighten his body my
body types too
Titan is like uh
uh like rope is made not Titans like
scared flexion
is a torque or torsion through my body
you understand
okay
cool here never here
try a motel you'll find it easier the
timing is more subtle on right